You're gonna be turning 75.
You redefine what that means.
As you reach each milestone age,
I wanna know what impact,
if any, does the number have on
you?
I don't think about my life in
terms of numbers. First of all,
I ain't never gonna be old
because I ain't got time to be
old. I can't stop long enough
to grow old.
I'm just gonna be the best I
can be at whatever age I am,
and I bet you I won't look much
different when I'm 95 if I live that
long 'cause I'm like the Gabor
sisters. I'm gonna look like a
cartoon. I'll have on makeup.
I'll look as young as my
plastic surgeons will allow me,
and it's, like, all in makeup
and lighting and all that, but I
think, more than anything, it's
about what comes from inside
you. It's an attitude and,
you know, you gotta shine from
within, and sometimes that can
make you feel young and make
you seem young to other people.
You know, what I love about you,
every time I've ever talked
with you over the years, and
you were on The Oprah Show
multiple times. You have never
been one of those women who has
been reluctant to talk about
plastic surgery. Do you know
how old you were when you first
started getting
plastic surgery?
I think about 40.
Really?
I think I started--yeah.
I started thinking, when I was
about 40, "Oh, I need a few
little nips and tucks and little
pulls and sucks and whatever
we get," you know?
'Cause I'm a firm believer--
whatever it takes to make you
feel better about yourself--
if you've got the nerve,
and if you got the money, and,
you know, you got the need for
it, if it's gonna make you feel
better about yourself--if you
feel good about you, you can
make people feel better about
themselves because you feel
good, so I think...
And you always felt good. You
always felt good.
I remember--you know, obviously
times have changed, but you
obviously remember, years ago,
when men on television would
make jokes about your curvy
figure,
about your boobs, about your
wigs, and you once told
Barbara Walters that the joke was
on them because you knew
exactly what you were doing
with your image.
Were you ever hurt, though, by
any of those jokes, or did you
always know that you had
created this image, and that
was a part of where you were
headed. That was a part of your
own marketing.
Well, in my head, I knew where
I was headed because, to me,
I'm not a natural beauty, and I
was always--
I wanted to be pretty. I was
that backwoods Barbie.
I was impressed with that, and I
just always felt more inside
than how I looked on the
outside, so I really patterned my
my look after the town tramp in
our hometown, the trollop,
you know. The one that would
kind of walk up and down the
streets and get in a car and
ride off for a few minutes,
come back and get in another
car. You know, I didn't know
anything about that part then.
I just knew she was beautiful.
She had all this beautiful
blonde hair, red lipstick and
makeup, tight, short skirts and
high heel shoes, and I just
thought she's the prettiest
thing I'd ever seen, so I kind
of patterned my look after that.
I always loved the Frederick's
of Hollywood magazines. You
know, that was just kind of,
to me, how I felt like I wanted
to look, so- in the early days--
to answer the first part of your
question--I think it used to
bother me that, you know,
when people--well, I mean, it
didn't--didn't change me,
it didn't make me do it
different, but I kinda get a
little embarrassed sometimes if
somebody made too much fun of
it, but that was when I knew
they didn't know who all I was.